j'aurais parlé en circonstances de cause
puisque j'étais une enfant de la DASS et
j'étais une enfant battue et à force
d'être réprimandé d'être puni de se
prendre des claques dans la gueule
des injustices des humiliations totales
alors effectivement ça me fait de vous
une personne qui est complètement
différente avec des émotions des
ambitions qui sont complètement
surdimensionnés mais ça ne laisse des
énormes séquelles mental et affective
donc je demande à tous les gens qui ne
regardent en aucun cas de lever et de
punir les enfants à des des
des séquences et des émotions extrêmes
qui nous laissent des traumatismes à vie
dans l'affective et dans la vie
professionnelle ne portez pas la main
sur les enfants et ni sur les chiens je
parle des chiens également parce que
j'aime également les chiens et voilà
donc voilà et je parle vraiment en
circonstances de cause et peut-être que
vous pouvez pouvoir me répondre à ma
cycose il y a à ma situation familiale
en ayant vécu ce cet acharnement
physique
alors effectivement ça fait de vous
quelqu'un différent ça c'est sûr tout à
fait et d'ailleurs marine pourra
s'exprimer plus longuement là dessus
puisqu'elle est spécialisée en
neurosciences et donc avec
neuropsychologue
il y a des conséquences effectivement
sur sur la structure du cerveau et
lorsqu'un enfant est exposé à des
violences alors attention je distingue
je parle de violence et je parle de
récurrence de violence je parle de
violence plus ou moins intenses on va on
va garder quand même mesure de tout cela
on voit effectivement des modifications
et ça peut aussi
altérer certaines fonctions comme
l'apprentissage un enfant qui aura été
exposé à des violences va peut-être
avoir une mémoire beaucoup moins bonne
qu'à notre enfant qui aura été élevé
dans la bienveillance des problèmes de
concentration il peut y avoir aussi
d'autres pathologies qui peuvent se
déclencher tu peux tu peux peut-être
laisser un mot sur ce sujet
la chose on observe aussi une différence
structurelle au niveau du cerveau ces
enfants là il une diminution enfin en
tout cas une ce qu'on appelle une
atrophie dans le jargon de 10 à 20% de
certaines structures cérébrales donc ces
enfants là ont des cerveaux plus petits
alors ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont moins
intelligents nécessairement ça dépend
aussi de tout le parcours de vie
évidemment mais voilà ils partent avec
un
une difficulté supplémentaire alors
juste tu voulais répondre à Gilles je
crois
comme d'habitude j'ai hâte de t'entendre
on parle pas de violence on parle pas de
maltraitance on parle d'éducation
faut-il punir les enfants je sais pas
commenter le
métaphysique
de manière éducative donc j'ai hâte de
t'entendre vas-y parce que si c'est toi
le symbole de la punition on est mal
barré vas-y tais-toi écoute enregistre
la première chose c'est que articule
bien vas-y ferme bien ta gueule
la première chose c'est que moi
je pense que j'ai été éduqué par mes
parents pardon père et que j'étais
effectivement dans la crainte et dans le
respect de mon père et de ma mère et je
voulais que ça change absolument tout
évidemment et comme j'ai été dans la
crainte de mon père et de ma mère qui
mange je pense bien éduqué et bien élevé
alors évidemment je parle pas de coup
hein mais moi j'étais dans la dans la
crainte de ce que les pensées ma mère de
ce qu'elle est pensé mon père donc dans
le respect de mes parents et je pense
que ce qui manque aujourd'hui avec ses
principes à la con dont tu fais
référence c'est que à force de dire aux
enfants fais ce que tu veux tu vas être
taper à l'âge de 16 ans oui bonjour
monsieur ici gendarmerie il t'en garde
un peu parce qu'il a piqué de sa vieille
ou il a monté un truc de digue etc tous
les jours je pense que la vraie le vrai
problème aujourd'hui et ça je suis très
sérieux entre quand on parle de retour à
la au respect à l'autorité etc tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire là on est en
train de détruire totalement totalement
nos enfants parce que c'est absolument
aberrant qu'un enfant soit ne
comprennent pas très tôt et très vite ce
qu'est ce qu'est l'autorité
respect de l'autre voilà et ça je vais
vous dire que c'est principal autorité
respect et et j'irai adhésion si on ne
fait pas ça à un enfant vous en faites
potentiellement des délinquants des gens
des des enfants à problèmes des mauvais
élèves à l'école et moi j'étais je
remercie mes parents de m'avoir aidé
comme ça j'ai voulu faire tout l'inverse
et je peux le dire ça a été échoué ça a
été une fois voilà non pourquoi tu me
brandis ton nom
mais ça fait 3000 ça fait 3 minutes j'ai
fait l'inverse de ce qui m'a rendu qui
m'a moi qui m'a élevé ce qui m'a rendu
service j'ai pensé l'inverse j'ai tout
donné à mes enfants voilà pas de ce qui
va pas du pognon des cadeaux des machins
les trucs et c'est un désastre alors ça
marche pas là ça ne marche pas ça ne
fonctionne pas alors et d'ailleurs je
vois bien parce que Julien le premier a
été élevé avec un peu plus d'autorité
comme par hasard il s'en sort un peu
mieux Simon il a été élevé alors lui
pauvre il était vraiment bancaire entre
les deux et ça va ça va mieux mais
c'était très compliqué Enzo alors Enzo
ça a été le chouchou l'enfant roi je
pense que c'est voilà c'est pour
l'instant c'est pas terrible et
effectivement aujourd'hui avec mon petit
dernier parce que je me suis fait des
enfants
Gabriel et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
Gabriel effectivement aujourd'hui Il a 2
ans et je le mets au piqué alors vous
allez me dire que je suis un monstre
avec
personne
et quand effectivement 3 fois tu dis
Enzo et Gabriel va là maintenant on fait
ça qui dit NON NON et bah il dit quoi va
au piquet